there is a new report from axios
reporter jonathan swann
which tells the story of a donald trump
temper tantrum in which after losing the
2020 election trump tried to just pull
troops from around the world now you
might think that's great i want to bring
our troops home we shouldn't have troops
all over the world the way that we do
and i would agree with you but this was
not a foreign policy calculation by
donald trump this was not a well-crafted
decision to reduce the military presence
around the world this was not uh
a calculated
and uh much discussed
uh strategy for reducing the spread of
the american military throughout the
globe this was a temper tantrum over
losing the election on november 9th of
2020 you might remember that's the day
after the media finally said okay joe
biden won
john mcentee one of donald trump's
favorite aides
gave a note
to army colonel colonel douglas mcgregor
and on that note it said this is what
the president wants you to do
get us out of afghanistan get us out of
iraq and syria
withdraw completely from germany and get
us completely out of africa and mcgregor
explained you know we can't really just
do this by january 20th
and i certainly just can't do it by
myself and mcentee said to mcgregor well
do what you can
and mcgregor said i really can't do
anything i need like a real order from
the president i can't just go and pull
all of our troops from around the world
two days later and this is all based on
jonathan swan's axios reporting such a
letter was delivered to the acting
secretary of defense christopher miller
all u.s military forces are to be
withdrawn from somalia by december 31st
all u.s forces are to be withdrawn from
afghanistan by january 15th with similar
unrealistic dates and miller wondered
what the hell is going on here the
department of defense called the white
house lawyer pat chipoloni and asked
what is going on here they called
trump's national security adviser robert
o'brien
no one had any idea what was going on
this wasn't a plan
this wasn't policy this was just a very
strange temper tantrum and as jonathan
swann writes for axios the u.s
government's top national security
leaders soon realized they were dealing
with an off the books operation by trump
himself
ultimately it didn't happen but as you
can see this is not the action of a
president who wanted to do these things
because they were the right things to do
if they were he wouldn't have waited
until november 9th of the last year of
his first term to do it it was a
triggered tilted man
furious that he lost
seemingly wanting to create as much
chaos as possible for joe biden who
would be replacing him just two months
later and as jonathan swann writes quote
christopher miller told associates he
had three goals for the finer final
weeks of the trump administration number
one no major war
number two no military coup and number
three no troops fighting citizens on the
streets of the united states
think about the insanity of the
situation
when the acting national security
adviser acting secretary of defense
says my goals for the lame duck period
are preventing trump from starting a war
preventing trump from using the military
for a coup and preventing trump from
deploying troops to fight citizens on
the streets of the united states the
more we read stories like this one the
more we realize just how insanely close
we came
to an even greater level of chaos the
stuff that was apparently narrowly
avoided
almost makes the january sixth
insurrection look relatively mild in
comparison and between the riots
and trump trying to overturn the
election results and stay in power and
on a whim saying pull all troops from
everywhere and having lawyers in and
talking about martial law
or seizing voting machines or whatever
else
the stuff that happened is bad enough
but look at all of the things we're
learning about that almost happened and
as i've said when donald trump left
it was way worse than we knew
over time we're going to learn more
but i don't know that we'll ever really
learn the full scope of exactly how bad
it was and this is just yet another
thing and it i know that you know there
are probably going to be people in my
audience i've already seen it in other
enclaves there's probably some people in
my audience who maybe identify with what
is sometimes called the revolutionary
left who will say this was trump
outflanking the left on the spread of
the
american military trump was trying to
pull troops from all these places that
troops arguably shouldn't even be in and
now leftists like david pakman uh are
saying that it was a bad idea i'm not
saying it was a bad idea and i've been
arguing for drawing down troops in
germany and in many other places for a
decade on this program the point is this
wasn't policy this was the day after the
election was called for biden trump
without consulting with anyone and for
no strategic reason for no well thought
out foreign policy reason just says i'm
going to create an s storm for lack of a
better term for joe biden and just start
pulling troops haphazardly it is not
policy and this is not how anybody who
is a thinking individual would say it
should be done we should be drawing down
troops we should be reducing our
military footprint there's no question
about it but if you do it as policy you
don't do it once you're already a lame
duck that doesn't make any sense and
that's pathetic
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free when you go to the link right
underneath this video